est-ce que tu as tout vérifier
des crs pour acquérir les bons réflexes
soixante élèves en alternance de ce
centre de formation en agriculture
suivent ces jours-ci cette formation de
prévention c'est pas le travail aux
champs qui est prédominant c'est
vraiment quelle est la conduite des
tracteurs sur la route et quels sont les
législations pour être vraiment dans les
règles on est vraiment apprendre à bien
faire sur la route ans et ap bac pro bts
ces jeunes ont parfois tout juste 16 ans
et peu de notions du code de la route
sam apprend toutes sortes de choses ça
me prend toutes les bases toutes les
bases ont fait de la théorie on fait de
la pratique c'est ça qui est ça notre
porte dans cette formation la sécurité
après quand même amélioré le voir ce
qu'il faut pour faire et faire aussi
élément déterminant 75 % des accidents
avec des engins agricoles se produisent
sur les trajets professionnels on est
sur la route on n'est pas à
l'exploitation on est dans une parcelle
donc c'est un peu le but de notre
mission justement les sensibiliser là
dessus et se dire que beaucoup
d'accidents riche sur la route et ils
n'ont pas forcément connaissance de à 16
ans de tout là tout ce qu'ils les
réglementations et législations
gouttière l'opération intitulée 10 de
conduite agricole fête ses 50 ans cette
année une initiative née en 1972 d'un
groupe d'assurances qui permet de former
deux à trois mille jeunes parents les
sinistres corporels c'est très important
dans le monde agricole donc forcément
tous les messages qui sont donnés la aux
jeunes sur ces demi journées vont
forcément avoir des incidences sur leur
comportement de manière générale sur le
matériel mais également sur les gens
qu'ils vont côtoyer dans leur quotidien
aujourd'hui on estime qu'il ya trente
fois moins d'accidents tracteur qu'il ya
40 ans